the difference between men's and women's
friendships is for a woman it matters
who you are not what you are I what you
do for blokes the first question blokes
usually ask each other is what do you do
and the question is because it matters
what you are not who you are who you are
is completely substitute
what is the social brain hypothesis for
people that aren't familiar with it
essential brain hypothesis is really an
explanation for why monkeys and apes
have much bigger brains than anybody
else in the natural world and why we
if you like is the top end of the
monkeys and apes uh family tree have
exceedingly big brains and the question
is what do we use these big brains for
and the social brain hypothesis says we
use it to manage our relatively large
very complicated
societies it's that that allows us
really to hold these things together
as a coherent Village
to borrow an analogy rather than sort of
scattered individuals who never talk to
each other why wouldn't it be the case
that we got bigger brains so that we
could throw better or so that we could
talk in more complex ways or so that we
could grow cool hairstyles or do art
uh most of those things
um aren't that computationally demanding
sewing is probably the most complicated
of those uh and it's true that we do
throw better than
uh any of the other monkeys and apes but
that's really mainly because we've our
arms are freed off
uh from because we don't walk on them
obviously where it's monkey snakes
um arms have are used for walking on
um but we're our aiming isn't
necessarily better than other species
that Chuck stuff out like spitting
cobras or uh Archer fish that
spit out Jets of water and knock insects
off branches they actually probably are
more accurate than we are now most of
these things you know even walking
requires some
uh computation by the brain some
calculations but what seems to be really
important for monkey snakes is the fact
that they live in these very
dynamic social environments in which
relationships between other people
are constantly changing through time and
it's being able to manage those not just
the memory problems being able to manage
and predict what's going to happen in
these relationships and how to
integrate effectively with them within a
social system because the big problem
you have is if you're too rude to
everybody else they have a nasty habit
of either clobbering you or just walking
away and you know going to live
somewhere else with the over their
shoulder comment that you can look after
yourself if you're that clever
so it's the skills of diplomacy as much
as anything else these are actually very
sophisticated and computationally we've
shown
with neuroimaging experiments brain
scanning experiments that they're much
more demanding in terms of neural
recruitment than say ordinary
um logical thinking in terms of sort of
standard causality a causes b as it were
and I think part of the problem is
because what we're having to do with
physical things and if I if I throw my
spear in this way will I get it to end
up at that Target those are things in in
the real world but the the social world
what we do is build a kind of mirror
um world in our minds uh people by
avatars which which are based obviously
on the folk out there
um but we're it's what we're doing is
trying to in our minds trying to
understand
somebody else's mind and and it's that's
where it starts to get complicated
because if I've uh uh um got to um try
and figure out what you're thinking
about somebody else thinking who in turn
is thinking about somebody else
elsewhere uh in order to you know sort
of decide which Pub we're going to it's
something as simple as that
it starts to get notoriously difficult
you know get get five Democrats in a
room and you get five different views
right so
computationally uh having theory of Mind
modeling what other people are thinking
is hard
scaling that up Beyond yourself and one
person or three people or five people or
150 people becomes ever more difficult
so the the real simulation hypothesis or
the first version of The Matrix is us
trying to work out whether or not we're
going to I can convince everyone to go
to the pub that I like to go to tomorrow
right that's interesting you said
there's a really great quote from your
new one uh the social brain humans have
only had to Grapple with the stresses
and complexities of living in large
societies for less than 8 000 years
what is the evolutionary story of human
social groups that
okay so natural human groups if you like
the kind of societies we've lived in for
Heavens probably the last two million
years or so
are the kinds of societies we still find
in hunter-gatherers all over the world
so these are what are called fish
infusion or dispersed societies where
the community doesn't live all in one
place they probably own a bit of
territory if you like
um but the the whole Community is
divided up among a number of much
smaller Camp groups
the sort of standard size for these
communities
is about 150 people the world over among
these kinds of societies but the size of
groups they actually live in what are
sometimes called bands uh or the living
groups as perhaps a bit more appropriate
for a name for them typically somewhere
between about 35 and 50 they're almost
never bigger than 50 for one very good
reason
that is everybody ends up killing each
other basically
um
homicide rates go through the roof why
why would that be the case uh it's just
well the reason is simply the reason
um it that humans live in these
dispersed Societies in the first place
and it's the reason why primate
societies are as small as they actually
are if we put it in those terms
it's it's simply the stresses of living
in close proximity and this is not just
our problem it's not a monkey innate
problem it's a mammal wide problem now
these stresses come in two ways
the the uh indirect version is that
um given that you're trying to get
everybody to the same Pub for lunch when
you leave the sleeping tree
um
the difficulty for any mammal is that as
they're foraging on their way and
especially back to the to to to the
chosen sleeping trees for to spend the
night in
what tends to happen is animals just get
dispersed as it were over a big area and
eventually they those kind of the groups
fragments and animals go off on their
own this is what you see right going on
right for your eyes in in herding
species like deer and Antelope and so on
um they break the groups break up very
quickly they're coming together when
they need to come together usually as
protection against protest so if a
predator hove's interview in the
distance everybody sort of clumps tries
to find the nearest
um other folk to to to to gather
together with
um birds do the same and see them on
Shorebirds very nicely but you know as
they forage they kind of drift apart and
especially if the activity schedules get
out of synchrony which is a perennial
problem
if some animals are bigger than others
so species that have
um dimorphic
um
body size as well so females are much
smaller than males the females have to
go to rest because they fill their
stomachs long before the males do so the
males typically in these new seeds and
going on in Deer and Antelope and
they're like you know the males will
carry on feeding when the females have
all gone to rest and so the group's
naturally fragment
that that's a perennial problem for all
of them
and if
well your choice is that you know sort
of you can form
casual groups or herds
um and that solves your problem but the
risk you run with that is
um that you're caught on your own
uh the one occasion in the month when a
predator turns up
at which point you are lunch
um because basically predators don't
like attacking groups that that's why
this grouping strategy is so common
among among birds and mammals in general
um so the advantage of of the sort of
herding strategy is it's
pretty Costless in terms of cognition
you don't need a big brain to do it
because individual relationships are
basically Anonymous all you have to know
is uh you know
am I going to you know if I get into
fisticuffs with with this big thug am I
going to lose or not I'm going to lose
don't do it stay away keep away from
them that's all you need to do so the
only permanent kind of relationships you
have are between females and their
offspring and of course they don't last
forever because once The Offspring
adults they they effectively become
Anonymous members of of the herd and go
their own way so so the alternative way
is to do it the way
um species like the primates as a as a
collective but also some other mammals
mostly species poor groups the the horse
family the elephants the Dolphins uh the
camels especially the South American
camelids
they form permanent stable groups
multi-generational uh stable groups that
um don't on the whole lose individuals
um
particularly easily usually because it's
quite difficult to go and join in other
groups and the only way they can become
smaller is by breaking up into two
which is what they do but to have these
stable groups is very cognitively
demanding because you need to be able to
exercise the skills of diplomacy and
that seems to be cognitively very
expensive and that's why you need a big
brain but there is another cost now that
kicks into place which is actually what
drives
this tendency for mammals in general not
to live socially and that is the
stresses incurred from bumping up
against folks so this is you know the
sort of Los Angeles freeway problem
you're just grounded by cars or
alternatively you might say the the New
York subway uh at Russia problem where
you're just sort of hemmed in by people
uh who are constantly bumping up against
you not necessarily maliciously or
intentionally it's just that it is
crowded space and inevitably people just
kind of bump into each other and so on
and those kind of stresses uh have a
terrible effect on female reproductive
Endocrinology so they they basically
shut down the menstrual system
and they do it very fast if if the
frequency arises uh frequency of these
kind of stresses uh gets up to a certain
level it will completely shut the whole
system down
um this effect is so strong in basal
mammals so the generic not terribly
social
not permanent group living mammals that
you know they might live in small groups
that it's actually sets an upper limit
on the number of females that can live
together at about five
and as far as primates are concerned
that means you can't have a group with
more than about 15
individual synonyms females are always
about a third of the total group in
products so this would naturally and at
that point you're only just breaking
even even as a female in terms of your
reproductive output to replace yourself
so that's kind of uh the best work the
best you can do under the circumstances
if you need to live in groups ideally
you're much better off flipping in on
your own as a single female I mean
you'll have as many males there
apparently as you like
um it because what creates the stress
is that seems to be whatever females are
doing to each other we didn't quite know
what's going on didn't you tell me that
um concealed ovulation in humans could
be explained by the fact that it stops
other
women intersexually competing with them
by stressing them around the time of
their ovulation so that it could cause
exactly this disruption and maybe mean
that they couldn't have kids during that
cycle this is this is uh one of the
possible explanations yes for concealed
ovulation
um the other is it encourages male
competition for you
um because uh um they don't quite know
whether they've um fertilized you or not
so if you have a free-for-all kind of
mating marketers you have in many mammal
species so it encourages the males to
stay around and and that then gives the
females more choice
presumably also protects the infants as
well
not necessarily no
um I mean what what actually primarily
the problem that most mammals face need
most birds as well is actually predation
risk
um or what comes the same thing but
probably not quite so widespread is is
um ecological competitors in other words
the folks in the next door Valley the
next next group as it were intruding
onto your your feeding territory but
predominantly it it seems to be
predation risks and for that it is group
size so if you look at what affects
female fertility in these groups
um it increases with the size of the
group which is what we'd expect the
group is providing the production
um so the bigger the group The Higher
fertility is is getting because the
females are being buffered against the
external stresses but at the same time
the more females there are in the group
uh the
um worse their fertility is going to end
up with these hump shaped uh fertility
curves when you plot fertility against
group size or against
um number of females of the group turns
out that the number of males in the
group contrary to what I spent 40 years
trying to study ironically
the number of males in the group has
absolutely zero effect
um I'm not sure if that's entirely true
right the way through but in general
they don't have an effect there seems to
be a tendency
um
some species for females to exploit
males as Hired Guns basically as as
protection
um uh um so you see this in gorillas at
some extent you see it in species like
Gillard from possibly hemodrist lagoons
but predominantly
the males are just kind of
as we
believe to be the case in in primatology
since the 1960s early 70s is the males
are just freewheeling operating around a
Honeypot really for females Gather in a
group the males will map onto them
um you know otherwise they just kind of
go wandering
um but the the the those effects The
Mating effects that you see then really
are a spin-off or whatever
the social structure or social
organization actually is and that
depends on how many females there are in
the group but you run into this problem
whereby
um the more females there are the more
they destabilize each other's
menstruals endocrinology and risk ending
up in Fertile you even see this in
humans so polygamous households are
generally less fertile than than
um
uh monogamous households it's just
within a given culture that's
interesting so
it seems like
females have this balance that they need
to strike between the
um amount of protection and or resources
that perhaps a partner or a group could
give them with how many other females
does being a part of that group expose
me to and if you have too few resources
or protection you are at risk of
predators but if you have so many
resources and protection that other
women have gravitated toward that group
you are then suffering this
Endocrinology yes [__] that goes up
yes so so and this is the trade-off
essentially it's the trade-off between
survival in the face of particularly
predation risks so you know are you
going to make it through uh to adulthood
and you know once you get to adulthood
are you going to be able to hang around
long enough to reproduce yourself
um on the one hand and on the other hand
the fertility direct fertility costs
that seem to arise from these these
stresses and I hesitant to say this is
not
uh in this particular case the females
going out and beating each other up
necessarily this is just uh um the fact
that they are cluster if you like
they're kind of clustered together in in
the center of the social World therefore
they're bumping up against each other
much more this does spill over in terms
of human hunter-gatherers though because
it turns out
that uh homicide rate so the proportion
of all deaths that are due to homicide
just increases linearly with the size of
the living group in in contemporary
hunter-gatherers to the point where
a group of 50 is the sort of standard
living group size uh Camp group size
um something in the order of 50 of all
deaths are due to homicide and these are
not warring the consequences of fighting
with your neighbors a lot of this is is
internal
um fighting most of it of course is is
uh you know consequence of uh badly
behaved males
um and um a fair share of the victims uh
women uh um but not exclusively so
there's an awful lot of males get
clobbered in the process and this seems
to be simply a consequences of the
rising stress levels spilling out into
uh as the tip of the iceberg as it were
into outright violence that that ends up
very easily in humans with with uh
because of our weapons as they were uh
with with
the one party or the other uh being
killed
at 50 of mortality due to
um uh homicide this is not very good
news for the group's ability to produce
Offspring to replace itself and if you
go much above that I suspect you are
very quickly into demographic negative
territory in other words the group is
shrinking rather than from growing well
I think what probably happens is it
oscillates around what seems to happen
in primates is when they hit this upper
limit of fertility uh effect the what we
call the infertility trap
um what happens is the group oscillates
around a sort of um average value
because it it sort of uh starts to
because it's not reproducing because
it's too big it loses members through
death and then that brings the the group
size down below the threshold so
fertility kicks up again and and the
group starts to build up and it just
keeps doing this until eventually it'll
partition into two and you get get
fishing you see that going on in
primates all the time it seems to happen
in human groups as well though
whether that's uh the same
cause underpinning it is is not clear
but but you see the same pattern in
small-scale human groups
um uh the the the problem for
hunter-gatherers simply is that
you cannot have 150 members of the
community The Wider community living in
the same place at the same time
um because you would end up with by the
time you get to about 90 people you uh
100 of all your deaths would be due to
homicide at that point you're well
you're probably already gone extinct yes
wow very very serious now what we've the
surprise if you like is because we've
always assumed that the reason
hunter-gatherers live in these dispersed
societies is for ecological reasons it's
a tough old life out there you've got a
you know you can't walk down to the
nearest uh supermarket and pick some
stuff off the shelf we've got to go
around you know shooting animals
trapping Ducks you know digging up some
Roots there and there and it's hard work
um but the answer seems to be actually
maybe not the problem is just the
stresses and tensions uh have driven
them apart but they want to keep that
Community with within bounds so that you
know on the odd occasion when some
serious uh uh probation event occurs or
or or you know or you're raided by some
Community from some tribe from elsewhere
um you can get hold of them quickly
enough to band together in what's
effectively a kind of herd and of course
that extends out through the community
up to the level of the tribe is sort of
usually somewhere between a thousand and
two thousand people who've distributed
over much wider area
but this flexibility seems to allow them
to cope both with the kind of
survival consequences of you know living
in the natural world on the one hand but
also managing the fertility problem now
the in general the way primates handle a
fertility problem is what the females do
is form alliances with each other so
they form these grooming clusters
um two or three animals only which just
buffer them enough to defer the
fertility the negative fertility effect
that still kicks in eventually
um
uh but it but it but it sort of allowed
it defers it enough to allow them to
live in bigger groups so you've seen you
look at how primate societies work the
species that live in ever bigger groups
um seem to have broken through glass
ceilings and there seem to be about
three glass ceilings they push through
at each step they're introducing some
new
capacity in some way uh which allows
them to hold down uh well both to keep
the group coordinated and stop it
disappearing and uh over the horizon or
half the group does it being Over the
Horizon on the one hand but also manages
the stresses and conflicts within the
group at the same time and they think
depending on how big the group is they
seem to kind of manage that in in
different ways and the species that live
in very big groups by very big groups on
we mean on average only groups of about
50 which are what you're saying
chimpanzee communities and baboon a cact
type
um so the smart social primates uh what
what they exploit is these very high
level cognitive skills which are
extremely expensive
um uh computationally so they require a
lot of neural processing so these are
things like mentalizing the ability to
inhibit pre-potent responses which is
basically
not to let the Red Mist rise when
somebody
um so there's two issues here's I like
to put it you know that in the sandpit
of life this is how you work at
kindergarten you know you're all in the
sandpit playing together and and
somebody walks past you and kicks sand
in your eyes now the question is did
they do it deliberately or was it an
accident right it makes a big difference
how you respond
if they did it as an accident
what you need to be able to do is to say
it was an accident I'm not gonna you
know clobber them or kick Sam back in
their face uh uh uh because it wasn't
intended if they did it deliberately
then you have a second step which says
okay you know do I do I behave as the
um sand pit bully and beat them up for
kicking sound in my face or do I talk to
them nicely and try and talk them around
and and use the skills the diplomacy to
avoid
upsetting the stability of the social
environment so if you know if you exert
violence in response to uh uh somebody
else annoying you then that tends to
destabilize
um the level of equanimity in the in the
group at the community as a whole so it
tends to cause people to want to to
leave so if you want to keep them
together you have to exercise these
skills diplomacy and these are very
cognitively demonic because they they
require this business this capacity to
inhibit the Red Mist when it rises and
go hang on no no calm down calm down
take it easy
that requires in turn mentalizing
abilities because you have to be able to
figure out you know what were they
trying to do you know were they trying
to
uh annoy me or was it all an accent or
what how many times have they done this
before did I see them do it to my
friends yesterday yes yeah and and one
of the things then what becomes very
important in primate is a whole bunch of
kind of high level but not quite so high
levels the other two cognition skills
which are generally wrapped in as a
general thing known as executive
function skills so these are causal
reasoning analogical reasoning things
like that and one thing that primates do
which nobody else can do
uh it's Unique to the the anthropoid
primates and depends principally on a
bit of the brain that doesn't exist in
anybody else's brain is one child
learning they're extremely good at
inferring rules general rules from one
observation because they you know
everybody else is doing Association
learning which means they've got to see
it happen lots and lots of times and
then they go oh yeah that's that's
happened
15 times out of the last 20 occasions
yeah but because they have the capacity
for more mental processing they are able
to extrapolate out from a single event
more effectively okay so the the thing
that I'm finding interesting here we've
got this you know two million years ago
up until 8 000 years ago period we then
have this evolutionary mismatch coming
smash transformation how is it the case
given all of the things that you've just
said the homicide rates the fertility
messery all of that
how so first how do we get into agrarian
society and then secondly how is someone
living in an eight million person City
like New York yep yep with difficulty
that is the answer
okay okay so the answer to the first one
is what you see in the archaeological
record around 8 000 years ago at the
beginning of the Holocene so after the
last ice age
people started Living in villages
right up to then they'd lived in these
dispersed communities from about 8 000
years ago uh they initially start living
in in villages that are Community size
so they're about sort of one to two
hundred people
so it looks like the three bands that
make up a community hunt together
Community have locked together and uh um
uh lived in live in one space and those
very very quickly grow
uh in size going through town sizes of
uh maybe a thousand people up through
sort of
small cities classic
Neolithic cities and perhaps 5 000
people in the jerichos and the uh so on
uh of life and then of course you know
beyond that they very quickly become uh
King's kingdoms and and and nation
states and and where we are now
there's two questions here one is
why did that happen
uh secondarily why did it happen where
it did because actually it happened
across a band a latitudinal band right
the way across the world at the same
time
um and secondly uh uh how on Earth did
they do it in other words how on Earth
did they avoid killing each other
just to be blunt
um the answer to the first question
uh is very interesting because it turns
out that well
historical sociologists have thought for
a long time this is a consequence of
raiding primarily by by the folks in the
next door Valley as it were
um the question is why would rating
happen at that point the answer seems to
be the population just exploded
after the Ice Age and the reason it
exploded
well let me put put it this way
what in retrospect we kind of realize
now is it only exploded in this very
narrow latitudinal band what's known as
the
um subtropical Zone which is a very
narrow 12 degrees of latitude zone that
lies above the tropics uh immediately
above the tropics and sort of
buffers the temperate zones in the
northern and southern hemisphere so you
know in Europe and Asia and America and
North America you know most of those lie
in the the temperate zone but
um just it sort of separating the
tropics proper from from the temperate
zone system very narrow uh band called
subtropical Zone that turns out some
subtropical Zone has very interesting
properties because of the way in which
the growing season and pathogen
densities
correlate with latitude
turns out to be in a kind of magic space
where pathogen densities which decline
pathogen densities are very high at the
equator
this is famously described uh uh uh in
terms of where it where is it good to
grow cocoa West Africa why because it's
hot sweet and sloppy that was the uh um
classic definite definition of good
ground conditions that's perfect
conditions for
um for pathogens so the kind of the
closer you get to the equator uh the
higher the pathogen loads you get the
pathogen loads die away
um rather fast the further north and
south you go from the from from the
equator by the time you get to the top
of the tropics and the northern side at
least
pathogen densities are about as low as
they are further north in in Europe and
Asia but growing season
is still quite long so you haven't got
into the temperate zone where where you
start to have proper winter so you've
got lots of growing conditions are
perfect and at that time after the last
uh Retreat of the last ice age the that
temperate zone across the old world
in particular was absolutely rich I mean
the Sahara was Lush and green with big
rivers and lakes in the middle of it and
hippopotamuses and crocodiles having fun
together and fishes and baboons and all
sorts of stuff which now
uh don't live anything closer than about
a thousand miles to further further to
the South because what happened so you
have at this particular point in time
you have this sudden burst of richness
population has just explode and suddenly
you've got a lot of people uh competing
for space and resources and when that
happens the easiest way to get hold of
uh any kind of resources is is basically
to steal it off your neighbors so the
response was to try and live in in
groups now that they happen to solve
the the stress problem
um but what's interesting is is just if
I talk about that particular what
happened around four and a half thousand
or four thousand two hundred years ago
uh there was a massive climate change
event and um the uh Sahara dried up as
as did so you've got all the sort of
Rajasthan deserts in India and and so on
so forth right away around the around
the globe basically in these uh
subtropical zones and things got very
nasty as a result of that because
there's a lot of political turmoil that
happened uh but but they I'd rather
encourage them to kind of live in ever
bigger bigger cities I guess
but the big problem I think at this
point and we've always seen again the
Neolithic is all the time we invented
Agriculture and obviously that's why we
lived in villages so we could all sort
of work on the land together and the
answer is well actually nobody ever does
that you know show me a culture anywhere
around the world where everybody in the
village cooperates to dig a patch they
all have their own patches
right
um you know it's not until you get into
commercial scale
uh farming to feed Empires you know Rome
etc etc etc burgeoning populations in
Europe in the in the medieval times that
you start to get commercial side
plantations where you have lots of
people working together or employed to
work together
um on farms prior to that and everywhere
else in the world even now you know sort
of peasant farming is is done by the
family that's it you don't necessarily
need a big family you can
uh and what's more
um
it's become clear from the archeology
that
uh growing cereals was actually invented
before people started Living in in um uh
villages it predates uh the first
settlements about a thousand years
obviously it's not very easy to to to
have big farms if you have a nomadic way
of life but still you know it's possible
to have some kind of temporary farming
sort of effect Horticultural kind of
effects and that seems to be what
they're doing now the big problem they
had was literally
to how to avoid killing each other and I
think what they did was introduce a
whole in fact we can show this with
living the transition between living
hunter-gatherers and living
horticulturists living in slightly
bigger groups of 100 to 200 people
um they introduce social institutions
which allow them to manage as a
community manage the stresses and
particularly to manage
um uh the kind of violence that tends to
erupt among among young males so what
the kinds of things you can see and
these are brought in sequentially as
they hit glass ceilings in in terms of
community size things like Men's Clubs
where they can kind of sit down the the
classic one which Highway site because I
think it's just such a lovely example is
what the American Plains Indians done so
people like the Blackfoot and so on uh
um normally they lived dispersed her
together in his life in in small groups
of 50 to 70. then once a year they
gathered together for the Buffalo right
they got a thousand people crammed
together and all their teepees all those
classic photographs of the 19th century
uh what they did uh was have a whole lot
of Institutions which allowed them to
manage uh um stresses and particularly
any outbreak of violence within the
community one of which was to introduce
a police force that they would take all
the young men from one wall and the men
of fighting age if you like from one and
together at band and say okay this year
you're the police force uh you know your
response for going around and and
knocking a few heads together when
necessary but what they the other thing
they did when uh there was a bit of a
brawl broke out perhaps between between
two idiots is they would take them
they'd have a special TP the PCP they
would sit them down the PCP make them
smoke a peace pipe together and all the
other men are sitting around the outside
edge of the TP and make them talk to
each other and sort out their problems
in front of everybody else and then
everybody comes out of it
it's like a Neolithic version of Jerry
Springer or or counseling or an
intervention of some kind you have the
Talking Rock hold the Talking Rock now
it's my turn to have the Talking Rock
yeah yeah so so so those kind of things
so those Men's Clubs you see them all
over the place in these kinds of
societies sort of post post
hunter-gatherer societies who don't see
them in hunter-gatherer societies uh at
least I've never found an example of
Kirk one so just register Robin so what
you're suggesting is that as the um
group sizes began to scale up
the only way that you could restrict
this over 90 people 100 of homicides 100
of death being due to homicide is
through a rudimentary social
institutions uh yeah kind of legislation
early legislation cultural technology is
probably more shame and guilt and
accusation stuff like that
yeah it's it's pre-legislation there's
not a lot of kind of formal legislation
in other words there's no Judicial
System they tend to appear later
right they they do come in but they come
in at much bigger group sizes
uh what you get in this kind of black
hole period space somewhere between
living group sizes of 50 and living
group sizes of about 400 is this series
of things so in addition to things like
men's club you get charismatic leaders
so these are you know people who have
authority and Power by virtue of their
acknowledge skills maybe as a hunter
maybe possibly as a warrior maybe the
prestige just because they're wise you
know and they they they're perceived as
as producing you know the wisdom of
Solomon whenever there's a kind of
discrete and then on top of that there's
things like feasting uh both feasting
within the community itself but feasting
with neighboring communities in sort of
big you know once in a while
um events which build linkages across
and then also what you see is things
like uh marriage or marital arrangements
so you have
um uh
marital obligations which particularly
young men have to do have to go and live
and work for uh the bride's
um family for for so long or the fact
when when the couple get married they
have to go and live with with the
bride's family for a year or something
those kind of things these kind of
obligations I think what they're doing
is creating
a actually you're doing two things one
is they're expanding the pool of
potential mates which is what usually
keeps young males contented you get
problems in all societies when there's a
shortage of women basically and so if
you expand the pool if you're a very
small group the chances that everybody
every baby born one year were male by
pure chance quite High you know so you
end up with a bunch of guys with with
net with no prospects for marriage that
is an unhappy mix right so if you expand
the size of the the grouping to include
the next door Community
um then then you uh increase the
possibility of of everybody finding a
partner but also cunningly what you do
is you produce another bunch of people
who have a vested interest in your
relate marriage working you can also
bring pressure on you
um uh to behave better so it all is kind
of interesting little checks and birth
that that seems to get you through in a
series of steps almost like glass
ceilings where new things are added into
the mix up to about 400 400 what's
interesting is Judicial Systems start
kicking in you start to have
um
uh formal laws judges uh you know police
forces and you have doctrinal religions
and what's doctrinal religions are
interesting for basically is is two
things one is uh some sort of moral high
God wagging is maybe her finger as the
case may be uh in the in this in the
spirit world as well whenever you
disobey uh or whenever the mere mortals
disobey and and do things badly this is
not quite the same sense of moral High
Gods you get in the what sometimes
called the axial age relations which
appear sort of
around about 3000 years ago
um also
um uh which are often monotheistic these
are much more like tribal Gods but but
they're imposing a discipline from above
making people stick to the kind of
generic
um uh codes of good behavior as much as
anything but at the same time what
religion does through its rituals is
create this sense of commitment and
belonging which so you've got to
top up top down and a bottom-up effect
going on you've got this and bottom-up
effects in this context are always
better as we know well you know you can
have the most Draconian police force in
the world and the most you know um uh
Draconian judges and the most Draconian
penalties for breaking the law uh but we
still break the speed limit because the
chances of being caught are you know
modestly
um uh thin so you've got a good chance
of getting away with it and and and and
you know you can make those kind of
penalties for everyday laws like that as
draconiously like people will just
ignore them and get on with it and do
what they intend to do if you
have that built into a a kind of moral
code which is sanctioned by a goddess or
gods in some form it puts it in a
different plane you're saying if a
higher power is watching my speedometer
yes now that the thing is you know when
you're driving down Route 66 in your old
jalopy nobody can see what you're doing
out there in the desert okay for him but
there is somebody who's watching
somebody's watching a speedometer so
okay I mean this is fascinating the fact
that we have this
um kind of a little bit like an arms
race between the externalities that come
from group size yes and the technologies
that then need to be developed it's
almost like they're Predator prey
ecology thing that you would see
throughout Evolution
um I'm still struggling to understand
why these bigger groups
came together at all if what you're
saying is that individual families were
the ones that were farming
I at this stage I don't know why they
have decided to pull together into four
hundred and one thousand person groups
this this is almost always to do with
protection from raiding it's in uh the
farming bit is simply the way of
provisioning
you know if you've got
500 people a thousand people living
together you very quickly exhaust the
natural resources of the kind used by
hunter-gatherers in your immediate area
so if if you're going to uh feed
yourself in the way we've always done
the Santa gatherers it means you're just
being pushed to go further and further
and further out uh you know at some
point it just becomes impossible in the
whole system will collapse in Starvation
in effect
um farming solved that for us so it
allowed us to live in villages because
we could kind of do all that food
production close by without having a
real driving newly cycle along yeah yeah
I mean in the end of course you know you
exhaust the land if you overuse it but
that takes smart cultivation and cycling
of crops and so on and so forth all
those clever things can come in that
mitigate that a bit but there's nothing
you can do you know if you go killing
Antelope and and uh you know sort of
eating cutting down fruit trees for for
for firewood and all that sort of thing
that we we insist on doing
um uh in a way a hunter-gatherer might
you very quickly empty the land around
you and that that the sort of circle
expands further and further out whereas
obviously you know you can grow food
um uh like cereal or something like on
relatively small pieces of land and you
can keep doing it year after year on the
same bit of land eventually you might
have to lift the entire Village and move
somewhere else but that's a thousand
years down the road you know we can let
somebody else worry about that the Next
Generation can deal with it you know
farming works fine you know uh for for a
generation with it rarely causes many
problems in that sense when you start a
new a clear new land and stuff on it
um so so the the agriculture bit which
isn't very complicated at the end of the
day and as I say it it the
archaeologists now agree I think that um
you know people started doing Simple
agriculture well before they started
Living in villages but you know it's an
easy solution to the food problem the re
I think the real big problem uh they
struggled with was how to keep the lid
on the stresses of having people in
compact areas and it really looks like
you had this explosion in population
and this is why only happened in this
Zone it didn't happen anywhere else
because the population sizes or at least
the conditions for population growth
weren't anything like as bounties as
they were in in the northern subtropical
Zone it didn't happen in the southern uh
subtropical Zone
um partly because there isn't so much
land down there and also partly because
the land is much more uh desert-like
right the way around the world because
the rain shadow of the Andes on the
Argentinian planes there and so on and
the South African High valve these areas
have always probably been like that uh a
sort of grass and basically not very
productive so so you you never seem to
have had this transition from
hunter-gathering into to Agriculture and
settlement down there that you had in
the north and and it is still the case
that all the uh folk who live down there
historically and and sort of still some
extent survive down there predominantly
or at least until very recent uh
historical
um times uh we're all hunter-gatherers
you know there were there were no
serious settlements until until let's
say 500 years ago something like that
when essentially agriculture was brought
down uh from from the Northern
Hemisphere so
um
uh you have these rather peculiar and
special conditions in in the north north
northern subtropical Zone which sort of
kicked off this population explosion
triggered this sort of retreat into
um uh defensible positions that's why a
lot of these places are built on uh you
know sort of natural uh hilltops and and
the like think of the Iron Age forts in
in in in
Europe northern Europe but you see this
response all the time historically and
it's a well-documented response we look
at the uh American Indian populations in
the southwest in their response both to
each other as you had the kind of um uh
nadene speaking peoples coming down
intruding down into into the area of
these these original tribes
um uh but also the Spanish later coming
up uh from Mexico uh their response was
always when things get tough they
retreated from their nice rich Riverside
um uh villages and went off onto the top
of mesa's uh which were much much
um uh more defendable and you see
exactly the same thing happening West
Africa in the 18th and 19th centuries in
response to slaving by Arab and African
slaving Expeditions which were fueling
the transatlantic trade the the the
target populations would Retreat from
their nice flat Valley bottoms
um up into the hills because it just
made it much more difficult for for
raiding parties particularly horse-borne
raiding Partners to move around up there
much more defensible you see it
um
in the 19th century early 19th century
in in Zambia
um where a lot of the the chewa for
example who spread out into Malawi in
response to slave raiding by the Zuni
um uh
um uh MP is coming up from from from uh
further south in in in South Africa in
around the tall and places
um uh the Zulu uh um uh raiding passes
after the big Zulu Civil War in the in
the 1830s they were forced to retreat or
they opted to retreat again up in in
into the mountains from their nice
Valley bottoms and it was only once
slavery uh and these um slaving
Expeditions uh in these particular cases
were uh stopped uh as a result of
European uh colonization of these
interior bases that people went back
down again you know once once the threat
had been removed they kind of went weepy
it's a bit Grim up here in the clouds
and back down they go so this is a kind
of natural response by by humans really
to Clump together and find defendable
positions to live in
why two questions first one how did
women mitigate the messing up of their
fertility cycle given that they're now
we're now talking about 400 000 person
groups living together is it simply that
when you have a house and there's a
little bit of land in between you and
the people around you that you managed
to buffer that impact and then secondly
is it simply a case of continuing to
scale what you've suggested there which
is
you increase the group size you increase
some cultural Technologies and some
social institutions to deal with it is
it a straight line from 400 people in
the Neolithic period to Manhattan in
basically I think so my view has come
round to be
all this stuff uh can be explained
basically as a consequence of demography
and the stresses the demography the
costs and the benefits introduced by by
demography essentially
um
the the issue of female fertility in
these contexts are very interesting as
to how they've Managed IT I think a lot
of it has been
the imposition of external
um uh control if you like at a societal
level so you know that there are laws
um
um sort of uh uh you know sort of Ten
Commandments saying you can't do this
and you can't do that and in different
forms combined with
um the imposition of some sort of
judicial system says that you know sort
of miscreants can be duly punished and
and uh this this helps to you know
people do occasionally learn if they're
punished to behave better
um but also there's a sense in which it
you know it's an example that Paul is
ultra you know for the others you know
don't do this kind of baby because
you'll just get into trouble so all
those kind of things help in their
little in their little bit
um
I I think that
and you know that clearly had makes it
possible for people to live in big
groups because and it's clear that you
know when political control or judicial
control whatever you want to call it is
lost as in times of Civil War the whole
thing just falls apart and collapses
very very quickly
um Mayhem and and and you know just okay
you have to look at Ukraine uh um I've
been a people just behave incredibly
badly whenever basically whenever they
have the free hand
um
uh so but but that's the sort of big
scale I think there was still a lot of
things going on beneath the surface
which played a very strong role at the
women's level in particular uh one of
them and this is I'm sure very very
ancient is this tendency for women to
have a best friend forever a BFF
this is a kind of foreign territory for
blokes right you don't really find them
invokes I mean if you ask people do you
have a best friend they'll go yeah Jimmy
you know I have a point of beer with
Jimmy every every Friday night or
something down the pub we meet up and
I've known him since we were at primary
school they tend to be actually very
long lasting those kind of friends and
men's friends much longer lasting than
women's best friends forever
paradoxically but they're very very few
and far between and they're very
substitutable because if Jimmy decides
to go off to Thailand for the rest of
his life
you know Chris just shrugs his shoulder
and go oh it's great we had a great time
but you know Pete will do
is let me just substitute Jimmy with
Pete okay and everything is exactly as
well before that doesn't happen with
women's best friends and this is a
reflection of the fact that women's if
you look at all the literature on
friendship and all the work we've done
on friendship women have these very
focused personalized friendships
culminating in the best friend forever
for knowledge very very tired what we
used to call platonic friendships
because they're rather like romantic
relationships in their intensity but
they don't have the sexual element to
them right
um uh those those kind of friendships
however they are brittle
um like romantic relationships
they're built on trust and you can
tolerate a lot of
um small
um breakdowns of trust you forgive them
and forgive them forgive them but
eventually you've had enough and
everything terminates catastrophically
and you never speak to each other again
does the amount of intensity cause a
degree of pressure that's sometimes
difficult to keep up with
that's possible but I think these
relationships are hugely
supporting as it were in providing a
kind of both in keeping the pressure
because the way these these grooming
coalitions work in monkeys and apes you
know is there not
kind of um attacking uh
um alliances in which uh you know
um does happen from time to time but by
and large you know it's it's not built
around your friends sort of Leaping in
with their swords and and uh and shield
flying everywhere uh because you've got
attacked by somebody else the way it
works is passive defense it just keeps
everybody off your back and reduces the
pressure from you even within a large
social group
right so that that seems to be in effect
what what bet these best friends forever
are doing and they of course they're
providing lots of things like emotional
support and support during uh uh uh
childbirth uh and and in particular
um the the long
uh rearing period that that humans have
you know I would guess protection from
Gossip uh retributive Gossip against
yeah philosophers that are pointing
stuff in your direction yes that's right
I mean these are all the things that
just that allow you to dampen down these
kind of things it's not about excluding
you know solving the problem Community
it's just about getting the pressure
down low enough that it doesn't
rub off too heavily on you and Trigger
any of these kind of infertility effects
um you know whereas what I always
described the difference between men's
and women's friendships is is
for for a woman
it matters who you are not what you are
I what you do right for blokes the first
question blokes usually ask each other
is what do you do
and the question is because it matters
what you are not who you are who you are
is completely substitutable what you're
looking at is a club
um and you see this on on Facebook if if
this if there's two people in the
photograph the profile photograph that's
the profile photograph
what you'll see is uh
if it's a girl's page it's either
if it doesn't me and my mum or me and my
baby if they're the same age it's my
romantic partner or it's my best friend
forever
right and typically they won't have many
it's very rare for them to have more
than two people in in the in the
photograph if they have any at all other
than themselves if there's three four or
five people in the photograph it is
always the Blessed page and they're
always activity based you know it's five
blokes sitting in the fiver side
football goal mouth sorry soccer
from from the amateur Saturday evening
Friday evening uh games games we play uh
or it's five of us sitting on top of the
mountain at Machu Picchu you know or
it's five of us in our canoes on on uh
uh on the on on Lake Superior or
whatever it is you do it's always
activity-based so the definition of a
club is very casual right it can be as
casual as
uh can you get a glass of beer from the
table to your mouth without spilling it
if you can that's uh makes you a member
of the club and therefore anybody that
can do that consumption the club is
small it's four or five guys you can't
have more than that it doesn't work but
as I say you know if Jimmy decides to go
off traveling to Thailand it's too bad
there's a spare slot you know Pete is
just shoehorned into it and he goes into
exactly the same position occupied by
Jimmy and everybody treats him as though
he was Jimmy it's weird so I think
you're Jimmy now
um what what's what are the other
interesting differences between male and
female friendships how they relate how
they bond why they make up and break up
and what can predict their friendships
so the key difference really then it is
spun off this uh or perhaps make better
we're putting it actually underpins it
and that is in the way that uh uh um the
Dynamics of the relationship the way
it's built up and maintained with women
that is always conversation based
because they're always focused on
engaging
in a kind of discussions of emotional
content and relationships and the social
world on a one-to-one kind of basis and
what keeps women's friendships going is
the frequencies which they can do that
so if they move apart
whether the Friendship survives or not
into the future depends on how much
effort they put into trying to
have conversations with it might be on
the phone it might be on Zoom uh or you
know if they can't manage face to face
conversation has Zero Effect
on men's friendships and I mean zero
doesn't affect whether it dies or
increases
um and that's because their friendships
their social world is built around
activity it's doing stuff together
all right so my kind of iconic example
of boys bonding is there's used to be a
lovely picture of of two old Greek men
sitting in the sunshine outside of
Taverna uh either side of a table and
and every so often they would pick up
their uzo uh and or their coffee or
whatever and and take a sip and put it
down but they never said anything
this is boys bonding
okay conversation is absolutely honest I
mean you have to kind of talk to people
to get things going but actually you
know once it's going it what's really
important is is doing stuff together and
conversation then becomes much much less
important
um so that Dynamic then kind of bears
into
the size of that inner core of of
friends you know so whether you have a
this best friend phenomenon or not or
whether you just have this this five
layer of kind of uh best friends and
women will have a five layer it's just
that it's it's a kind of Hub and spoke
kind of uh um
structure in which the relationships are
between
Pairs of individuals where whereas the
boys uh five will be kind of much more
um
no I wouldn't hesitate to say the word
interconnected but it's kind of much
lower level and more diffuse in its
structure so that it's much uh better
interconnected in a network sense I
think that's why
um their apprenticeships are probably
less prone to
uh catastrophic failure than women seem
to be
um women's friendships and I said have
this fragile sort of characteristic to
them that they can suddenly just
collapse and break because somebody has
done something worse what tends to
happen with boys relationships is they
just drift apart because they just stop
bothering to see each other so okay you
know they might take a swing at each
other if one gets really annoyed but
usually what happens if
um they take a swing at each other is
they just go have a beer afterwards and
everything nobody says
that doesn't predicate the Friendship
continue it could actually be the
beginning of a great friendship so I I
understand what's interesting in this
context is boys will never talk about
why they had a fight
you know once it's dealt with right and
they've had a dream together
it's kind of never mentioned unless it's
mentioned as a as a laugh you know
whereas bitterness and resentment May
linger cool yeah they're much more
concerned to go and I want to talk it
through with you you know why'd you do
this and so Mike this is my observation
I'm kind of putting two and two together
but I'm very conscious of the fact in
this kind of restorative justice sense
where they you know the police will
offer you this opportunity to go and
talk to the prisoner uh who you know
robbed you blind and broke into your
house and robbed you blind or beat you
up in the street and stole your purse
off you it's I I'd be interested to know
what the uh uh actual percentages are
but my sense is it's always women that
want to do that and then guys yeah I
would not talk to him or throw them in
an octagon together
so I can understand I can understand why
it would be that women would have this
um predisposition toward the Hub and
spoke model especially with aloe
parenting especially with uh increased
physical risk uh high tolerance for pain
all of these lower tolerance for pain or
lower high sensitivity to pain
what is the Adaptive reason for why men
can have these slightly lower level a
little bit more diffuse slightly more
interconnected Cloud style relationships
and friendships as opposed to the hub
and spoke model
I I think largely it has I I don't know
I think the answer is we really don't
know I mean is this clubishness
in male relationships is kind of very
conspicuous in in the ethnographic
literature generally because you have
these age groups phenomena and you have
very specific puberty rituals for the
boys uh where they go through a group
ceremony and those groups establish a
cohort of similar age kids who are
bonded for life you know those age group
uh um groups are often more important to
to the young men and even older men than
their family relationships and that's
partly because a lot of these ceremonies
extremely painful circumcision
frightening take them out into the dot
into the woods in the dark night and do
scary stuff with them they're because
they're teenagers you know but it really
bonds them very tightly together and I I
my sense is they're kind of setting up
the communities if you like setting up
the Defense Force for the for the
village you know somebody's got to do it
you need some guys who will go out there
and stand together and not abandon each
other at the moment somebody raises a
club in their direction from from
outside as they were Raiders
um and are willing to
uh uh you know stand shoulder to
shoulder uh uh uh with the other guys in
defending the interests of the village
that's my guess but I don't think we
really have a good answer to that that
it seems a plausible answer to me but
it's and a lot of other people have
suggested much the same
um the the and I think for that you know
you have to have this this intensity
with a group it does it's not going to
work if it's a one-on-one kind of uh
relationship it has to be a generic sort
of you know
do you belong to my club if you belong
to my club I don't even need to know
your name but you must be you must be
okay I stand with you it's it's that
kind of kind of I always had it in my
head around the reason that men were
prepared to let their friends Drift Away
uh and sometimes come back but sometimes
not would have been
to do with perhaps big game hunting and
the risks of warfare that if there is an
attack
Pete might not come back it might be not
be that Pete's gone to Thailand it might
be that Pete's being gored by some
warthog yeah and if that's the case okay
I can be sad about people I can't be sad
about Pete forever whereas I'm going to
guess ancestrally that homicide and
deaths of of the kind accidental hunting
deaths and stuff like that would have
been rarer to women which would have
made the cycle the turnover of their
friend group less yeah
absolutely absolutely so and and there
are all sorts of interesting examples of
that so
um you know one of the interesting
examples of that is Eskimos at high
latitudes especially
um because life is very risky out on the
ice
so the women do not go hunting because
it's just far too dangerous and and the
mortality rate historically was so high
that a woman but women basically needed
two husbands to see herself through
through her life because yeah you know
in those kind of environments you have
to have somebody
bringing the food in because this stuff
you can't grow anything or at least not
through the winter
um so you had to have a member of the
household who could go and do that
and on the other hand it you could not
afford for women to do that because the
mortality rate was so great
uh that it would have just left a bunch
of kids completely off so the way they
seem to worked it out is to um
uh you know have that as as definitely
male only uh only job and I guess this
is somewhat similar with with deep sea
fishing in the Pacific Islands as well
it's only men that did that women did
inshore fishing but not deep sea fishing
um and also it seems that the eskimos
adjusted the sex ratio to ensure that
the woman had available enough men to
have two husbands
um
amongst those Eskimos no no it was
female infantic side seems
but remember you know you're living on
the edge of survival up there you know
you know it seems Grim to us but when
your choices you do some things which
may or may not be unless even to you at
the time nonetheless
uh it you know it's the difference
between survive surviving and not
surviving the whole thing can just fall
apart so easily under those sort of
environmental conditions so they're very
very exceptional in that sense as I
think yesterday but they're you know
sort of a nice example of how humans can
adjust their
behavior and social strategies and even
in some sense their psychology how they
see the world yeah that's what I was
thinking in order to do that because and
it and it's the way it was done is is
interestingly complicated to take the
pressure off the parents as well
um but but going back to the the way
the women uh try to manage these stress
effects I think one of the other
factors that's and I I'm kind of
um really only come round to this idea
quite relatively recently so it's not
terribly well thought through but it
struck me that uh some of the species of
primates that live in very large
dispersed communities have this kind of
horror-based structure which is very
much like what you see in
hunter-gatherers so you you have a male
with just a couple usually in that case
two or three females not too many
um uh uh which forming these small
family groups and it what it looks like
to me is the women using males as Hired
Guns
so you get this hard gun effect I mean
this is an idea that that goes back to
to uh
um uh MoGo Wilson
and a few other uh women ethologists who
came up with the idea back in the in the
80s
and argued there you actually see this
on the streets of big cities women using
men as essentially a Hired Gun and
conditions where they're exposed to
high levels of harassment and and threat
so in a context where you have large
numbers of males kicking around in the
community
you know the the sensible idea is to
attach yourself to a male who then
provides you uh with with protection
just keeps you know the idiots away from
you basically
um they don't necessarily have to go out
and and and and engage in fisticuffs
though presumably
uh if push comes to shove it's better to
have somebody who's handy with their
fists as somebody who's not
um but you know if if that's actually
that would explain why we have two
things
uh that are kind of peculiar about
humans one is why we have
these unusually have these live in these
very large groups with lots of males and
females around and have these uh kind of
pair-bonded relationships I use the word
pair bonded here rather than monogamous
because you pair bonded can be
polygamist in their pair Bonds in
polygamy obviously
um and
um the the
idea that they're actually using the
males as a form of protection then
um uh would explain why you get this
system and it also explains something
that's slightly peculiar about
human mate choice and that is it seems
to be driven predominantly by the women
right so
um we have some very nice telephone data
so it's huge samples this is all the
telephone uh conversations in a year
that take place in a single provider
from a large European country so we're
looking at six billion folks very very
large something and if you look at them
cross-sectionally across age it's as
clear as a bell
the girls start so we we don't know what
happens before the age of 18 because
that's the sort of minimum cutoff you
can't look at stuff before the age of
18. unless you have you know go through
big Hoops in in ethics things so for May
18 you see women starting to focus on
phoning a boy of about their own names
more and more increasingly it takes the
guys about the better part of five to
seven years to start doing the same
what I think is going on here and
there's other evidence which points to
this same thing the girls are making a
choice
very very early on who they want to go
for
and then they go
constantly battering on his door whether
it's phoning or just being in the right
place the right time or whatever
um uh until eventually even the most
stupid guy wakes up and goes oh goodness
well all right then
how would you um how would you how would
you square that Circle
yeah how would you square that circle
with the mail over perception bias of
attraction
foreign
that men on average seem to presume that
the woman that they're speaking to even
if it isn't yes incredibly platonic is
more into him than she actually is why
would the man have not cottoned on
earlier than five to seven years
um um I I think well there are several
reasons that's an interesting question
um but I don't know if anybody so what
we have here if you like is two
different bits of observation
which don't look as though they they're
up but nobody's actually ever bothered
to put them together so far partly
because I don't think they've kind of
you know people tend to look at one
problem at a time
they look at one side of the the one
side of the coin without looking at the
other at the same time so it would be
nice if people who do courtship studies
of this kind and made Choice preferences
they actually tried looking at both
together it might give us my guess is
that men are just much more casual
about these things right that does you
know I suppose you might argue well it's
because they're not everybody but my
sense is that if you look at any
relationship
if you just look at pictures
of heavenly married couples or pictures
of couples in romantic relationships and
just look at the eyes
the girl is always looking at the bloke
and the bloke is looking into the
distance somewhere over it's just so
real you couldn't make it up right so I
think what happens is girls have this
predecision to lock onto once they made
their mind up all right everybody wants
to marry Mr Darcy they've got a picture
of who the perfect uh um her partner is
going to be
and then they just go for it and and you
know sometimes you win sometimes you
lose but the point is at the end of the
day somebody has to get the thing off
the ground otherwise nothing will happen
you know they'll just sit on opposite
sides of the dance floor and uh and
ignore each other uh so somebody has to
get up and make make a movement and it
seems like the girls do it and and my
sense is that's because
they're one of the outcomes that they're
looking for is being able to have
what's effectively a Hired Gun just like
Margaret
um suggested
um uh uh uh big and that's because
they're making much more complex
decisions look at any of the literature
on mate Choice strategies which we did a
lot of work on using personal ads a long
time ago men make very simple decisions
it's basically
uh indices of fertility so
attractiveness and age and really
they're just not interested in anything
beyond that uh women are much more
demanding
in what they specify they're interested
in
and as a result they also say very
little about themselves other than their
age and that they're attractive so they
know that that's the only thing that
we've got to optimize for your Market
you've got to know the market yes
absolutely it is it is unbelievably
accurate that the two Sexes
understanding of what the other sex is
looking for in The Mating market and
they you know adjust their behavior
in what terms of what they have to offer
but what they look what they offer about
themselves uh uh sorry what they look
look for
um women tend to be much much more
demanding than males and I think it's
because they're trying to balance many
more different things
in the system because obviously kind of
from a biological point of view
this whole business is about
reproduction ultimately so you know
reproduction isn't just producing babies
it's all that follows beyond that in
terms of being able to rear them to
adulthood and so on
so I think you know the the it doesn't
surprise me previously that it's that
women should make an early and very
clear decision they're having to make a
kind of best of a bad job
uh choice because nobody
uh satisfies all the boxes
uh so you kind of do the best you can
you know and you know it's it's a
frequency dependent thing there is only
one Mr Darcy in the village right and
only one person is going to get them so
you know if Jemima gets him you have to
settle for the Cure it fine but at least
you that's your number two choice so you
know it takes enough boxes uh uh to
satisfy your your requirements so you've
got these very complex decisions going
which but it means they kind of seem to
make a much more focused and decisive
and early decision on whether to go uh
or who to choose and and the blokes kind
of just fall in line
um I'm sorry to say what are you working
on next so for me to try and track the
not only the frequency of books that you
put out which is terrifying but also it
seems
I can't think of a better word it seems
Meandering in a nice way we've got we've
we've had religion we've had friendships
we've had uh the social brain which kind
of applies friendships and and Group
Health to the business world uh we've
had stuff to do with sex and attraction
what's next what can people expect from
you next
well actually I'm still trying to sort
out what's going on in primate social
assistance and their evolution but I
think we now have
a coherent full story so the next book
is to try and put that all together in
one place because a lot of this
literature is very scattered in
journals all over the place and I think
one of the problems is people
uh don't see the big picture so it's
sort of become incumbent on me I think
to try and bring this all together
present the whole story and show the
evidence right and then the follow-up
book is uh applying that to humans
really so it's really doing the Friends
book with the data not the whole of the
friends book but the essence of how we
create communities out of uh essentially
friendships how friendships scale up to
create communities and why we created
basically what we've been talking about
but this time providing the actual
evidence in their certainness then once
I've done that
I think I'm exhausted uh of doing this
kind of stuff and I'm going to do
a history book which then applies all
this stuff to historical uh
um phenomena
you're a monster you're an absolute
Beast I just have fun
right you don't understand there is a
group of my friends who are at Cambridge
who are over here at UT and every time
that you release a new book or that
someone spots that a new book comes out
it gets posted in one of our group chats
saying [__] dunbar's written another
book again and I I still haven't
finished the proposal for mine so I look
I I absolutely adore all of the work
that you do I really really appreciate
your time today uh I can't wait to see
what you do next and I'm very much
looking forward to having the next
discussion about whatever it is
well uh it's a great pleasure always to
chat to you because it's such fun and um
thank you for having me yet again until
next time thank you mate
there you go all the best what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
foreign